c'est un pont aérien jusqu'à 18 avions
comporter par jour avec à leur bord des
tonnes d'armes et d'assistance
militaires c'est par cette base en
Pologne que transit les livraisons
promises à l'armée ukrainienne par une
vingtaine de pays occidentaux des
lancers
des opérations menées 24 heures sur 24
dans la plus grande discrétion
ce n'est pas possible de filmer ni de
nous parler ici
donc on doit partir oui impossible donc
de savoir précisément ce qu'il y a dans
ces conteneurs transportés par 6 camions
de l'armée française qui entrent dans la
base
les marchandises sont ensuite chargés
dans d'autres camions à l'apparence plus
neutre il ressortent et prennent la
route par convoi d'une vingtaine de
véhicules en direction de la frontière
ukrainienne
un ballet qui intrigue depuis quelques
jours les habitants de la région
toutes les demi-heures il y a un avion
qui se pose ici
des avions qu'on avait jamais vu c'est
quelque chose de nouveau pour nous
selon le Pentagone toutes ces têtes
militaires livrées à l'Ukraine et pour
l'instant efficace pour ralentir
l'avancée des forces russes mais pas
question à ce stade pour l'automne
d'aller au-delà même si des moyens
humains sont aussi prépositionnés des
milliers de soldats de pays membres de
l'OTAN sont arrivés en renfort dans
toutes les bases de la région il
participe régulièrement à des exercices
afin de renforcer la coordination
militaire entre les pays membres de
l'Alliance atlantique